joyeux anniversaire de deux semaines qu'est-ce qu'il y a
avec toi et comme des sacs de gens
harley elle est à la tête de l'équipe de suicide
tu n'as jamais répondu à mon e-mail pourquoi est-ce que tu
attises un drame en ce moment ce n'est pas un
drame d'accord qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire elle
porte une jupe crayon
harley  et lierre sont de retour
laissez la tournée bang kill commencer
bff gfx bien
[Musique]
c'est tellement amusant et puis torride et puis un
peu effrayant
oh c'est terrifiant
oh mon dieu
dois-je continuer ça ne vaut pas la peine
que la grande orgie commence
s'il vous plaît james garner il a enseigné  moi
là c'est
tu vas ramper quand tu entendras ce
plan ça ferait chier lex luthor son
pantalon cet homme ne chie pas son pantalon
pour tout
ce que tu